I don't exist so uh they're all
characters that I played including Jim
Carrey including Joel bearish including
any of those things they're all
characters Jim Carrey was a less
intentional character because I thought
I was just building something that
people would like but it was a character
I played the guy that was free from
concern so that people who watched me
would be free from concern you know and
uh and then at a certain point you go
like okay well that's great but you know
it's like the one thing like people talk
about depression all the time the
difference between depression and
sadness sadness is just you know from
happenstance whatever happened or didn't
happen for you or you know grief or
whatever it is and depression is your
body saying [__] you I don't want to be
this character anymore I don't want to
hold up this this Avatar that you've
created in the world it's too much for
me right you know